les chéris jean michel mr et ce soir
avec sa dulcinée
oui jean michel maire et sa famille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jean michel a quelque chose à dire je
suis très ému évidemment parce que riz
là je suis très ému parce que c'est vrai
que c'est longtemps que c'était secret
ou aujourd'hui c'est officiel donc c'est
vrai que c'est un nouveau départ
bon on va dire la vérité ça serait mieux
je consomme alors on va dire la vérité
ça n'est pas c'est nul faisait beaucoup
trop chic pour lui et beaucoup mieux que
ce que vous croyez
puisque ce n'est pas sa fille la fiancée
de jean michel maire mais c'est la femme
d'un ami très proche
alami que j'aime qui voulait lui faire
une surprise ce soir et vous êtes la
femme de
[Applaudissements]
et
cannes que j'adore j'aime très fort elle
est revenue au mariage et je reviendrai
à toutes les fêtes parce que je suis une
barre de bois ce que j'adore les fêtes
et n'est pas venu juste pour te voir
parce qu'elle sait que tu travailles
elle voulait pas vérifier si tu étais là
ta femme avait quelque chose à te dire
que tu peux tu es magnifique merci
qu'est-ce que je les aime l ambition
rigoler mais regarde le si si regardez
et écoutez nul 1-1 aujourd'hui je crois
tu es m 2 tanner une à toi une attaque
alors mon bébé ta femme voudrait pas je
te quitte
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est dur trop mignon donc voilà je vais
profiter de cette émission parce que je
sais que je suis tient beaucoup à cette
émission donc cyril m'a laissé venir
pour pouvoir te faire une petite
déclaration
donc j'ai préparé un petit poème pour
toi donc avec des lettres de ton prénom
donc voilà donc m comme mariage ça fait
déjà cinq ans ont des mariés donc merci
aux com
or comme les noces d'or donc j'espère
qu'on pourra un jour j'étais nos noces
d'or t comme tunisie le on sait
pardonner dans les rocheuses et plus
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
qui comme come down dirait mon café
mocha comme tiff en fait comme jeu qui
fera la vie avec toi on était comme
tunisie parce que c'est le premier lieu
on s'est trouvés ces rencontres et a
comme ayyub donc notre enfant preuve de
notre amour et d air pour un resto in ni
quoi qu'il arrive
bon sauf si jean michel maire me
détourne mais là non ça risque pas
d'être plus tard voilà je t'aime
[Applaudissements]
donc là
alors alors cinq ans de mariage cinq ans
de mariage
au fait ce week end willow est ce que
vous avez la piscine la piscine
ouais à toi boulevard mais pour moi
c'est call center est ce que je peux
m'occuper de votre week-end moi même je
vous fais qui fait je serais pas là faut
pas venir non alors est ce que j'ai
vraiment ma place dans ces cinq ans de
mariage
je pose la question de laisser ma tête
je ne sais pas si j'ai ma place
j'irai que je vienne je viendrai annoncé
dès le premier jour des gens de notre
région on part vous inquiétez pas je
m'en occupe d'accord on va passer tout
le week-end a kiffé bon je sais vous
allez kiffer et moi je vous je
regarderai je suis un organisateur
d'accord en facilitateur 1 1
carrément non j'ai envie de vous faire
kiffer ce week-end d'accord c'est bon
ayadi je kiffe tous les goûts avec toi
des beaux arts
je souhaite beaucoup de bonheur et c'est
son initiative elle voulait absolument
que faire une surprise ce soir à l'isi
alors merci docteur kay qui file à la
meute est que connaît pas content il est
pudique il
oui bah oui c'est pas ses patins michel
c'est sûr quand le shérif et ce week-end
c'est que du kif et je vous aime très
fort vous savez je vous lâcherai jamais
tous les deux vous le savez jamais non
mais c'est sûr c'est paraît il pas aussi
je sais que c'est pareil voilà donc on
est où maintenant on a trois on reste
[Applaudissements]
merci